what are cryptocurrency exchanges and
what's coinbase how does it work before
i'll ask even bigger questions but it's
just a nice kind of
pallet cleansing question of what is
coinbase
coinbase is a cryptocurrency exchange
brokerage custodian basically
we're the primary financial account for
people in the crypto economy how they
buy crypto how they store it how they
use it increasingly in different ways we
can talk about that um so yeah we want
to be the way that a billion people
hopefully access the open financial
system globally how does it work
what uh
what's cryptocurrency
you know there's uh there's bitcoin
there's ethereum
um what does it mean to be an exchange
what does it mean to store what does it
mean to transact how does it what does
coinbase actually do
okay so you know basically in any given
market there's some people who want to
buy some people who want to sell
and there's you keep an order book of
all those prices
and then um
you know if someone's willing to buy for
more than the lowest price someone's
willing to sell then you know you get a
trade to execute that's kind of how an
exchange works underneath and a
brokerage is kind of simpler than that
even you don't have to know look at the
whole order book and everything but you
just go in there and you say i want to
buy 100 of bitcoin or whatever
cryptocurrency you get a quote and if
you like it you can hit accept and you
know
the core things that we do to make all
that kind of just work make it seamless
it sounds simple on the surface
is we gotta we have to do payment
integrations you know in a variety of
places around the world to make it easy
for people to get fiat currency into
this ecosystem
we have to work on cyber security a lot
there's lots of hackers out there trying
to break into our systems and steal
crypto or to put stolen credit cards and
bank accounts and things like that into
these systems
um we have to integrate with the
blockchains themselves right which are
periodically getting updated and
having various airdrops and all kinds of
things so we're integrated with lots of
different blockchains and then we have
to store the crypto that people buy
securely as well so crypto is kind of
like storing
you store the private keys essentially
and we've invented a lot of cool
technology about how to do that securely
that helps me sleep at night
as one of the largest crypto custodians
out there
so those are some of the pieces that had
to come together to get that early
simple buy sell experience to work
and
yeah i mean coinbase actually has a lot
of different products now so we have
like an institutional product we we have
coinbase commerce which is like merchant
payments like stripe for crypto we've
got a self-custodial wallet which we can
talk about there's all kinds of cool
applications people are building with
web3 and they can access it through that
we just just launched an nft product
um i've gone down the list we have we so
we're sort of like a portfolio of crypto
products now we're big enough where we
can do multiple things but yeah the core
thing we got started with and still the
majority of our revenue today is people
just want to come in and buy and sell
some crypto and we help them do that
make it simple and easy to use uh and
i'll ask you about wallet and if t is
about com what is it called the stripe
type coinbase commerce coinbase commerce
yeah i'll ask about all that but uh
order books and exchange what's the
difference between
that and stocks for example which
there's also order books yes i mean
stocks trade through order books too uh
sort of commodities there's all similar
type of situation so when i want to buy
one bitcoin and i see coinbase say the
price of that bitcoin
is say forty thousand dollars
and i
press buy what happens
um yeah okay so you've gotten a lot
like
you know when you press the button on
your keyboard like electrical signal
goes up the wire on your keyboard
well that's also important the timing
right because it's not pricing
yeah it's true it's giving you a quote
right that's that's um
you know some there's a whole concept of
like slippage and like by the time the
quote is executed um if the price has
moved too much like we may reject it and
you know there's there's various things
like that but how do i i mean what's the
simple version i can give you so we you
know we'll we'll basically check the
order book give you a quote
it's good for some period of time or for
some amount of slippage and then
what's happening is we're initiating a
debit to your payment method whether
that's a credit card or a bank account
or
you know you're storing dollars or euros
or something on our platform there's
various payment methods so we're
basically debiting that and then we're
crediting you the crypto and um we're
taking a fee for it too so um
that's fundamentally what's happening
underneath and then there's some
interesting slippage how do you how do
you calculate the uh how much slippage
is allowed like how do you how do you
know these things
you know because order books are
fascinating
you know the dynamics of that is pretty
interesting yeah and the little i know
about it yeah so
there's a lot of people like traders who
get super into this and like high
frequency traders and arbitrage and all
kinds of interesting topics flash boys
was like an interesting book on this
whole thing you want like
access to information the fastest
sometimes even putting your
you know your thing in the data center
right next to the thing we don't we
don't allow that colo stuff because we
want it to be more democratized
um
but you know basically you give a let's
say we wanted to just keep it math
simple we want to charge a one percent
fee so if you're buying 100 of bitcoin
and we'll charge you 101
you know we've presented you the amount
of bitcoin you're gonna get for the
hundred dollars now let's say 10 seconds
later you hit accept we go to we go to
fill the order
so it's going to be
some error bound around that one percent
fee right and if we think we're actually
losing money on the trade i think we'll
often reject it so some part of the fee
the slippage is incorporated into that
averaged over
a large number of people and it just
just it's fascinating because like even
just like that little detail probably
requires a lot of experimentation yeah
and it's kind of like a giant bug bounty
out there because if you get it wrong
there's people who are going to
arbitrage that and we've we've had
people sort of pen test our systems in
you know really creative ways where like
um
they'll just fire like programmatically
with apis they'll fire off like a
million different quotes and look for
one of them that's out of bounds and
then actually take that money right
there and you know we get people doing
all kinds of crazy stuff but so how do
you protect against that how do you
protect so we'll talk about cyber
security in interesting ways but there's
a lot of clever people
trying to do clever things to earn
not even just to break into the system
but to earn an edge of some kind yeah in
the system
how do you uh how do you stay one step
ahead there's no silver bullet it's a
bunch of lead bullets right so it's it's
like
you know one thing we do is we just have
good test suites right so you're testing
every piece of code that goes out that's
like just common good best practice but
it's particularly important in financial
services
um another thing we do is we hire third
party firms to try to audit this stuff
and break in another one we do is we
have a bug bounty program
so
we
basically pay white hat hackers to find
this stuff before the black hats do and
um
we've paid out lots of good bug bounties
so
you know
try all the above and occasionally you
don't get it right and you lose some
money and then you fix it and you keep
going so
yeah let's talk about sebas security a
little bit more yeah you mentioned using
stolen bank accounts yeah so that's
another one that's another interesting
one how do you protect against that
okay so fraud prevention
yeah is a big topic so one of the uh
there's a lot of things people do but
one of the things they do is that
you use machine learning right so you
look at
protector to attack to protect against
it so
um what you want to do is kind of build
up a labeled data set of
all the different people who have turned
out to be fraudulent and good good
actors and hopefully collect as much
data as you can and then you'll you know
you might feed hundreds or thousands of
these factors into your machine learning
model it'll come back with a risk score
so you know an example of like the kinds
of factors people create or put in there
you know obviously i don't want to
disclose too many of them because it's
it's a cat and mouse game but just kind
of i don't know relatively well known
stuff might be
um
you know you have device fingerprints
right so like what kind of device are
you on and what fonts do you have
installed a lot of people who are
farming lots of these accounts they're
using emulators and like virtual
machines and stuff they're not like you
know an average person on that device
um and then you'll see sometimes like
one of my favorite metrics we track for
for this was called like improbable
travel velocity so we would we're
tracking people's ips right and you
might see someone um
who was one day in austin texas and then
like an hour later they were in london
or something it's like well that's very
improbable i mean sometimes people are
using vpns so you got to be careful with
that because like there's legitimate
people who use vpns too but
um
if it's not possible for them to have
gotten on a plane and gotten there that
quickly then that's usually they're like
spoofing a device or ip sometimes those
are interesting factors but yeah if you
feed enough of these in
you will see oh the another fun one is
like
you know real users will type their
credit card like one number at a time
yeah scammers have a list of them and
they'll just paste in a whole a whole
number
um so you can look at like the the
number of milliseconds between
keystrokes like there's all kinds of
stuff people have come up with you for
travel velocity you could probably
incorporate vpns too because there's
probably
a uh travel velocity for vpn switching
too that's human-like like if you're
using legitimately vpn for something
else yeah um that that might be there's
like legitimate uses too actually you
know i feel embarrassed that i don't
know this probably should but the i'm
not a robot
capture thing capture thing yeah so that
probably works in the same way like how
do you move your mouse maybe or how the
dynamics of the clicking totally
but how does that even work that well
then and why can't it be fake i need to
look into this because it's it's such a
trivial captcha it feels like should be
very crackable and yet a lot of
high security places use that yeah it's
really interesting it's another cat and
mouse game so i think they've yeah but
it's using a lot of similar signals like
mouse movements um keystrokes and then
obviously all the stuff that comes over
the the wire with your browser so like
what operating system what fonts you
know what headers are being sent over
and yeah um there's actually there's an
old website a camera was called it was
kind of like panoptix click or
panopticon or something but it basically
was like a proof of concept site that
um they would just show you all the data
that was kind of getting sent over with
your your request and like
you say that there's only one person in
the world who has this exact set of data
it's you and so it's almost like um
a work around a clever workaround to
track somebody
um make identify a unique person even if
like there wasn't a cookie involved or
something
yeah this is a fascinating world where
you can't see anybody you're in the dark
and yet you have a lot of signal you
have to figure out who's the real person
who's not who's a robot who's not
you